Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call. We've got a bunch of questions, so we'll jump right into it for those that are new.
You ask the questions typically on the members site. You have access to the member site and go on the member site.
And there's a box on each page that has questions for Zoom call and you can ask it right on there.
Otherwise, you can chat it in, put it in the chat or unmute yourself if you want to voice it in.
And let's jump to the questions. First question. I am new to the right machine. How do I navigate to all the programs?
Well, I didn't make a video about this how to navigate, but typically at your, you know, when you open up your computer, you'll see your home screen.
I have videos on your home screen for how to use your right machine. And I think on one of those, you would go into how to navigate, but then I created a new video on how to navigate your computer.
So go to your frequency course, go to the frequency healing course, and you'll see that on the home on the first module of the frequency healing course, how to navigate through your programs.
And the only people that have trouble navigating to the programs people have never used any Microsoft product before because it's basically based on all the Microsoft icons.
So you can go back a screen and, you know, you'll go to open program.
So don't be afraid of messing things up. The only thing time you mess things up if you drained things to something and dropped them somewhere different files or.
So it's all based upon your programs are based upon different file folders that each file folder has a program in it.
And that any of those programs you can run with your right machine. So don't be afraid of it.
Anything you would would possibly screw up is something we could fix.
So we do get calls from people that get a right machine for us to our full program. And then, you know, week later, they're still not running their program because they're afraid to open it up and try different things.
Everybody gets access to the frequency healing course. And it has every instruction you could possibly think of in there every time someone comes up with a question that is a new question.
And we've been doing this a long time. We still get some new questions.
Many times they will make a video on it. So, and they're on the frequency healing course.
All our videos are on our video site too. So you could literally search the video site with the search button and you'd probably get a video of your answer.
And even searching our website, you can get an answer to most of those questions. So don't feel bad about looking for these things on our sites.
And if worse case scenario, make sure you call us and we can walk you through that next question.
Can you explain some possible symptoms of chronic H pylori infection?
So H pylori is helicobacter pylori. And I do have some posts on our website that go into detail and how to care for it.
But this is a good question because I don't know that I go into detail with the symptoms though on some of the videos on those posts, I probably go into some of them, but maybe not all the symptoms.
So symptoms of chronic, how would I know I have a chronic H pylori infection?
Well, the problem is most of the time you won't. So you could have a chronic H pylori infection that's affecting your blood vessels and not have, and your first symptom be a heart attack.
So that is an issue. These silent infections, these chronic silent infections can be deadly.
So remember, you know, atherosclerotic disease is not because of plaque build up in the arteries or I should say the cause of plaque build up in the arteries, is it because of excess cholesterol?
Well, it's because of damage to the arterial wall. So the endothelial layer of cells that line the arterial walls, the vessel walls can become damaged for a variety of reasons.
It's also sustained heavy metal toxicity, Lyme disease, and H pylori. So H pylori is one of the top five players in endothelial damage, which leads to atherosclerosis, which leads to a heart attack.
So it also can lead to high blood pressure because H pylori bacteria could get underneath the endothelial and damage the smooth muscle layer as it adheres to different receptor sites in the smooth muscle and it causes contraction and it can lead to high blood pressure issues as well.
So many times when people have been diagnosed with high blood pressure, they've been diagnosed with high cholesterol. They've been there on medication for those things. They've had issues with micro strokes or TIAs. It's from a silent H pylori infection.
If a person has known cardiovascular issues of any kind, they should actually treat themselves as if they have an H pylori diagnosis because it is very possibly the player or the root cause of those things.
But other common issues with chronic H pylori is rosacea type issues. So you can have like a hot and cold kite flashes in the upper extremity.
You can have rashes on your arms. You can have rashes on your neck and face. Very common for those to be H pylori related.
The symptoms can vary because H pylori goes systemic. H pylori has a common issue with endothelial issues, that's vascular issues, common cause of skin issues and the common cause of cancers.
So any of those should give you a red flag to maybe possibly treat for H pylori.
As far as how you would treat H pylori, I go into that more depth than some of the blog posts, but the common killers of H pylori are going to be orang-un-grape, burberine, oregano, garlic.
Those are going to be your best killers of systemic H pylori or even H pylori in the gut. And they work on healing the gut and balancing the microbiota on the gut.
But usually when you're talking about chronic H pylori infections, it's called systemic beyond the gut, but it may have left damage in the gut to treat that as well as important.
Next question, I haven't going through gut issues. I did a colonoscopy and they couldn't get in due to a mass squishing the colon long story short. The doctor said it was impacted feces, all throughout the intestines stuck.
Then it out of severe pain in the back and diarrhea, yet never feeling empty, but going out for nine months, how do I get it unstuck without surgery?
Why would a person have diarrhea if they have an impacted colon? Because the feces that is able to get by the impaction has to be very watered down and then you have to have a diarrhea beyond that point, but you have an impacted colon with feces that's not necessarily all that uncommon.
How do you get it impacted? Well, first of all, your concern is if it truly is simply impacted feces because you've been constipated for in this case like nine months.
Then doing coffee enemas, doing colonics, to try to get that lucid up, colonics go much higher and deeper than a coffee enema, doing colonics, to try to lucid that up, would be something that I would try before you try to go in there and do something surgically.
Sure, they probably recommend oral things to have a loosen things up.
How does a person get so impacted? Because many times they've ignored this initial symptoms if you've been constipated and you've had abnormal stools for a long time and you just think it's going to go away.
Well, this is where it's so important to be on some fiber substances, some other things, some just straight butyric acid and some other colon healing things.
You know, we've said in not only the detox, the seven phases of detox course and my book on seven phase of detox, if you're not detoxifying, you're just toxic, you're toxifying.
So if you're not getting out with the inside, if you're not getting rid of poisons, you are becoming more and more poisoned.
That will lead to all sorts of serious disease that you can just list on a spreadsheet because ultimately it's going to lead to that.
So you have to get out what's on the inside, you have to get out poisons that are in your body.
You're just, if the more constipated you are, you're just going to be reabsorbing all your toxins that your liver's getting rid of as well.
Next question, what can I do for my daughter who has obvious hormonal issues?
Well, I don't know what obvious hormonal issues are, whether it has to do with frequent or infrequent or abnormal periods, abnormal bleeding at periods or you're talking about emotional hormonal issues, all those can be signs of hormonal dysfunction.
As a part, I don't know how old your daughter is, whether they're in their teens and they're just starting to get their period and they're just starting to deal with these different hormonal influxes.
If that's the case, diet plays a big role in these hormonal influxes because as we're, if you're eating a typical American diet, you're exposed to so many bad estrogens and estrogen disrupting poisons
and toxins in a typical American diet that it throws off your hormone balance.
When their newly functioning ovaries are just starting to work and their pituitary is just starting to kick out the different hormones and stimulate estrogen and progesterone production and balance.
So getting that balanced is really important. Certainly you could do a Dutch test, which is a dried urine hormone test to see where that person is at and see where the imbalance is to know how to deal with it.
Many times a person, a young lady who has got PMS issues and severe issues with their period has a deficiency in progesterone and abundance of estrogen and balancing it out.
You know, you can take exogenous topical progesterone that can be very helpful, but I always think it's good to look at the hormones through a Dutch test.
There's different nutrients that can help balance hormones as well. So if you're talking about hormonal issues that are more emotionally based and they're having severe mood swings and things, yes, that is tied to estrogen and progesterone, but it also can be tied to the adrenal and the thyroid gland.
So getting their thyroid tested, getting the needles tested, which would be done through a Dutch test as well, but getting their thyroid tested through a blood test, a complete thyroid profile would be very important too, because that can definitely affect moods and issues there.
Again, foods and diet is so important because it feeds back to the whole system, foods as far as the different foods that would be inflammatory, especially gluten, is going to affect the thyroid directly because gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland, and sugars are going to affect the adrenal glands.
So looking at it, you've got to dig it and it depends on how young this child is and how willing they are to manage their condition and make dietary changes, whatever you're dealing with a young person, that is a difficulty to, you know, in some cases, whether they're willing to make...
You know, it's hard for anybody to make dietary changes and certainly somebody in their teens that has got a lot of pure pressure quite over their friend's house and such.
So, yes, if you want to make do a case review, we could discuss this and decide on next best steps.
Next question, can I get a genetic test for family members? Is there a discount?
So for our full members, yes, we've typically, at different times, offered discounts for family members to get a genetic test.
So just call the office and we could discuss the options with that to move forward with a genetic test for family members.
It's not uncommon that we do a full genetic workup, but somebody we have our genetic review and this information is so eye-opening sometimes that it's like, oh my gosh, I'd really like to get a genetic review for my husband or for my child or something like that and that can be very beneficial for moving forward with their health issues.
Next question, is there a test to find out if you have leaky gut?
There is. There's a test to find out there because there's actually three different levels of, quote, quote, leaky gut.
So leaky gut is typically thought of as damage to the cellular border of the gut, the epithelial layer of the gut
and damage to the what are called the tight junctions, tight junctions separate and now you are allowing things to be absorbed into your bloodstream that should have never been allowed to be absorbed through your bloodstream.
And then you get this immune reaction to that thing because it's not just down to an amino acid, you're getting a larger peptide section of a protein and that's not ever supposed to be in your bloodstream and your immune system can react to it and you can develop antibodies against those things.
When you got circulated antibodies in the tissues and in the lumen of the gut and every time you eat that food or whatever, again, you have this immune reaction to that peptide and then you have this inflammation that takes place and that's what a food allergy, quote, sensitivity, quote, is all about.
And then that's just downward spiral of inflammation of the gut that causes more damage to the epithelial cell layer and more openings of different tight junctions and then you got even it just continues to worsen.
Now there's other levels to leaky gut as well you can actually have damage to the cells themselves where the where there's opportunity for things to pass right through the cell and into circulation that's like the next step of damage to leaky gut.
And then there's a third level damage to leaky gut where you actually have lipopolysaccharides being produced because of bacterial overgrowth, grab a negative bacteria, have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membranes and when that becomes, when that dies and becomes liberated lipopolysaccharides can then circulate through your bloodstream and you can measure those.
So if you have elevated lipopolysaccharides, that means you have even worse damage leaky gut because it becomes more of a problem because lipopolysaccharides directly damage the blood brain barrier.
So they damage the astrocytes that make up the blood brain barrier and now you have the leaky brain and that is a term.
So you actually have a damaged blood brain barrier and you have things getting into the brain that should not get into the brain and now you got inflammation of the brain and when you have inflammation of the brain you can damage microglial cells which are the immune cells of the brain.
And then they can become what are called primed damaged microglial cells and they can stay in the M1 state and dispute inflammation and cause this cascade of problems that leads to dementia and forgetfulness and Parkinson's and antibody production to neural tissue which is another cascade of problems where we get Alzheimer's and all.
And damage to mileage, she sells and demilinated diseases and all sorts of neural issues.
So yes, dealing with the gut which goes back to that chronic const patient type issue, you ignore things at your own risk, don't ignore things.
So when you have symptoms symptoms are there to tell you that something's wrong that you need to deal with it.
So make sure you don't just that's the problem with practicing medicine the way medicine is practiced these days.
You have a symptom just take this drug, you have a symptom, you know, we can also practice natural medicine that way you have a symptom just take this this nutrient that will maybe make the symptom go away but not deal with the cause.
The more you don't deal with cause, the more you suffer the consequences thereof.
So with anything in your life, you don't you always want to try to get to cause or close to it as possible in order to actually solve the problem.
So the test for leaky got the I think you know there's several companies that know adopted the same testing is for leaky got as Syrex but Syrex has the array to which would be the test for leaky got the test for all three levels of leaky got and it's a blood test.
Why do some people think that the covid shot can cause cancer?
Because it can so the covid 19 shot has been showed through numerous studies to increase one risk one's risk for cancer.
I cannot tell you how many people that we've had call our office that said they were just diagnosed with cancer and it was not long after they had the covid 19 vaccination or booster.
Or that their cancer came back with the vengeance after when it was in revision for a number of years after they got the vaccine and there's a lot of data out there.
I won't go into that anymore if you really want to search that data, there's research articles that have been buried that do show that increase incidents.
Cancer and what are called turbo cancers they've been termed turbo cancers because they can they can be very very fast growing cancers that nobody can seem to put the brakes on.
There's also evidence that the covid vaccine contained SV 40 as one of the components of the vaccine which is known cancer causing.
Particle that is used in laboratories to produce cancer in lab rats in order to test different medications against it.
So they'll give a lab rat SV 40 in order to produce cancer so that they can test their chemotherapy against that cancer.
Why would you put it in the covid shot are there nefarious reasons for all these things? Yeah well probably so I've said way back when covid came out that you do not want to get that vaccine.
Next question what's the negative of buying supplements through Amazon?
Well we do sell some of our supplements through Amazon. The problem that buying supplements through Amazon in general is that you don't know for sure if you're getting the real thing.
So you don't really realize how possible it is to for a Chinese company which I say Chinese company because 99% of the time it is a Chinese company that is doing this.
Literally buy let's say picket designs for health product or an ortho molecular product or a PHP product they buy it the bottle of it from the company.
And then they literally scan and reproduce the label and they fill capsules with literally just rice brand and they sell it as the product that's why most of our most of the most of the companies that we sell on our website on our store do not let us sell Amazon.
They don't let us sell it on Amazon because they otherwise it's too hard to chase down all these Amazon company so there's so many companies that are selling bad supplements already legally not just these fake companies that are selling fake designs for health products on Amazon.
But there's companies that are selling you know you can go to Walmart or Target and you can buy a bottle of ashwaganda and you can bring it to your local biochemistry lab.
And if you know the biochemist and you can ask him to test the is there actually 200 milligrams of ashwaganda in each capsule.
They'll find in most the products that you can even get at GNC target Walmart whatever they'll find that it contains less than 10% what it says on the label.
So it's just so much cheaper to buy it at Costco can't I just buy this product at Costco not saying that there's not maybe a good tumor product at Costco.
But you're taking your chances most of the stuff that you're getting is not good stuff.
A lot of the little supplement companies and things have been bought out by the drug companies too and they're not selling good stuff.
Why because they can because they could get away with it because nobody's getting attested they're not getting independent testing done.
So you have to buy reputable stuff or you're just not getting you know the real stuff.
I mean that's just there's there's been studies every reference them in the past multiple times.
Independent studies that have literally got it and bought products at different stores and Amazon and test it.
And they just don't some of them have nothing in it there was just rice brand.
And some of them had some ashwaganda or some whatever herb they were testing or supplement did have the dosage that was in that what that was in the capsule.
I was listed on the label so you take your chance.
I'm sleeping a lot 10 hours a day not good sleep.
Could my high HCB 10.1 and MCH 33.1 be a possible cause of tiredness I think is 30 minutes every day of sauna too much.
No admission I have no admission sore muscles and always tired what are the possible causes.
So is the possible cause 30 minutes of sauna every day I don't think so is the possible cause elevated MCV or MCH so let's kind of go through these.
MCH is an MCV are two of the measurements that you're when you're looking for anemia.
So elevated MCV and elevated MCH can be a sign of anemia.
So if those are elevated but your red blood cell count isn't suppressed your hemoglobin isn't suppressed in your hematocriticin suppressed one would say you have early anemia.
If your hemoglobin's low your iron's low your ferritin's low and your hematocritic low and then your elevated MCV, elevated MCH, elevated MCHC then you definitely have anemia.
Now the balance of all those is trying to discern which type of anemia and I have a blog post on this anemia so do search that.
So you have to kind of go through these is this high but this is low so MCH is mean corpuscular hemoglobin MCV is mean corpuscular volume so it's they're used to determine what type of anemia.
So what is anemia anemia is low red blood cells and but it can be caused from a lot of things so you could have higher deficiency anemia you could have B12 deficiency anemia you could have vitamin B6 deficiency anemia you could have folic acid folate deficiency anemia.
So there's different types of anemia that you have to try to discern what it is so if a person has has high MCH high MCV the possibility is iron deficiency anemia B12 anemia and folate anemia possibly B6 anemia.
And then you could do some other test to try to discern what is going on if the person does not have elevated homocysteine that it's you could probably scratch the folate anemia that it could be just B12 or B6 anemia.
If they have normal iron levels normal red blood cell counts then you'd think of B12 or B6 anemia.
Could that be causing tiredness well if that if you're trending worse and worse on these that I would say yes.
So lots of times I just had to discuss with somebody on the phone today too with early anemia is you won't get really tiredness so if you if you don't have low hemoglobin typically you're not going to really get chronic fatigue really exhausted tiredness and you're sleepy 10 hours a day and you're just you're still tired you feel like you have to take a nap and tell your hemoglobin
is really below 10 on average if your hemoglobin is still 12 13 you probably I would not say your tiredness is due to that remember your tiredness can be due to other things too.
So chronic tiredness or this low muscles can be due to low in a male low testosterone low adrenals can be due to low thyroid so in a female you think of low estrogen low progesterone low thyroid low adrenals.
So then you also look at do I have extra stress in my life can it be my adrenals are shot this is where adaptogens really can be helpful so adaptogens can help boost adrenals can help boost thyroid so if I take adaptogens
and let's say I'm taken three to six adaptogens a day and that really helps my energy that it was probably adrenals and or thyroid.
If I've been taking adaptogens every day and I'm taking enough to make a difference but that's not touching my tiredness at all then I want to do you know,
blood work again and make sure I don't have more you know more rapid onset anemia so because adaptogens are going to help with anemia adaptogens are going to help with hormonal issues if a person if a male has prostate cancer and they're doing things to reduce their testosterone
or they're on testosterone reducing medications like energy deprivation therapies it's not uncommon for them to have symptoms of anemia but not have anemia because low testosterone can give you these things no admission sore muscles feeling fatigued.
So you have to kind of break this down depending on you know blood work to put it on activity level but to put it on stress levels and figure this out so causes of tiredness causes of low admission causes of sore muscles I think I covered most of those things could be other things could be you know inflammation in the body
to eating foods that you have sensitivities to so let's have eating gluten I have a gluten sensitivity can gluten can that cause an inflammatory reaction it could cause these symptoms absolutely because if you're causing inflammation of the gut you're going to cause inflammation of the brain that's rule number one inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of the brain you got brain inflammation it can affect you systemically so it can cause all these symptoms
no admission sore muscles just exhausted can't get enough sleep tired all the time not sleeping well all these things tie together so you do a little bit more investigation to figure out why.
Next question I've heard you say that those with cancer should not take glutathione supplements because it could cause the cancer to grow I forget the specific mechanism at the moment.
So the mechanism of action of glutathione cancer is that glutathione to glutathione is your made you make glutathione in every cell your mitochondria makes glutathione actually recycles glutathione.
Glutathione is your made cellular antioxidant you have other antioxidant superoxide this retakes Cadillase to have other pathways for anti for dealing with oxidative stress so understand what oxidative stress is oxidative stress is caused by toxins caused by chronic infections creates an oxidative stressed environment of a cell
and a cell can only take so much oxidative stress before the cell could die could cause cell lysis cell death pathology to the cell the cell dies.
So other bad things oxidative stress can cause a can damage or organelles of the cell a can damage cell membranes it can damage the nucleus and it can be the cause of cancer so oxidative stress can be a cause of cancer
because the number one cause of cancer is oxidative stress. However what's a person has cancer so step back sorry to prevent cancer is to help support you know the elimination of oxidative stress which is the elimination of oxidative stress on a cellular basis is the role of glutathione is the role of your other antioxidant systems
oxidative stress can be the cause of cancer or at least a cause of cancer but once a person has cancer a cancer cell is replicating quickly is not replicating healthy mitochondria
therefore it's not making good antioxidants not have good glutathione production so a cancer cell itself is already a very highly oxidative stress and remember there's a threshold so there's a limit of oxidative stress that will tip over a cell and cause cell death
so a cancer cell is already near that threshold very close to that threshold of lethal death due to oxidative stress so think of a line and a graph and a cancer cell is much higher than a normal cell as far as the level of oxidative stress that's going on internally in that cell.
so most cancer therapies including those that are that you are doing which is if you're doing you know different herbs can cause oxidative stress to a cancer cell and it causes lethal death of the cancer cell
you know B-17 to S-E-A-C-2 to fenmentisol to Ivermectin to you know go on and on everything that I have you guys on is oxidative to cancer cells
now the nice thing about natural therapies is their oxidative to cancer cells but not to healthy cells so they spare healthy cells and they can kill cancer cells.
So is chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent to tip over cancer cells unfortunately chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells so it can damage healthy cells but every therapy out there is an oxidative stress therapy every cancer therapy is oxidative stress therapy
vitamin C is an oxidative stress therapy so if you're going to take glutathione while you're doing an oxidative different oxidative stress therapies you are kind of you're kind of negated the whole purpose you are taking glutathione you could be you could be causing cancer cells to survive the therapy that you're trying to use to kill them.
So therefore typically a cancer patient does not use glutathione that's the mechanism now you get your question would it be okay to take NAD as a way to naturally boost glutathione levels to help with detoxification
and if so what with the dosage you recommend I'm guessing that age 70 by glutathione levels are pretty low.
So no I don't think you should take NAD so they continue to my dioxide NAD supplements are not first of all really meant to boost glutathione levels NAD really boost nitric oxide levels which is a totally different mechanism.
So nitric oxide functions in a way to boost a whole different pathway it boosts vascular endothelial growth factor which if you have a hard tumor and you're not in you know complete remission
you could actually be causing your body to make new vessels into that tumor thereby allowing the tumor to be fed and to grow more rapidly.
So you don't want to take any nitric oxide boosters when you have a cancer going on now NAD works in other ways to to help mitochondria secondary effect helps glutathione levels NAD also helps
nitric oxide in the way that it helps with stimulate smooth muscle relaxation in the endothelial cells which is your vascular system.
So nitric oxide can help relax the smooth muscles of the endothelial lining and cause blood pressure to come down.
So there's a huge benefits to nitric oxide but if a person has a growing cancer you don't want to use nitric oxide because one of its huge things is to increase vascular endothelial growth factor which is super beneficial if you have cardiovascular issues
but not so much if you have cancer which is the catch 22 of let's say you have both you know very common people have cardiovascular issues but they also have cancer or the case of the person asking his question they have live disease but they have cancer live disease.
If you only had live disease I'd definitely be putting you on glutathione.
But if you have cancer too you try to help your body deal with live disease you could actually be feeding you know keeping a live cancer cells so there's danger to that.
Take NAD that can be very helpful for live disease or cardiovascular issues or high blood pressure issues but it can also cause a cancer to grow.
So some of the things that are good for cardiovascular people or good for for live disease people or chronic infection people are not good for cancer patients.
And that's the danger of you know take say this nicely getting advice from a practitioner who doesn't truly understand cancer.
Most people that come to me are getting advice from a practitioner and they're on supplements and they shouldn't be on those supplements given the diagnosis of cancer but just because I am a practitioner this is what I would put you on because you have cancer so you should be on glutathione because you really need to decrease oxidative stress because oxidative stress is the cause of cancer so we're going to get you on glutathione but you already have cancer.
So you don't want to go on glutathione so not understanding that piece can be very deadly so you know don't do that you'd be careful where you're getting your advice certainly you don't want it to be from Instagram influencers.
So and it better be a practitioner that understands your diagnosis is taking that into consideration understanding these things or they should be going this is not my specialty you should talk to somebody who that's more their specialty next question.
For what is it not able to do coffee animals and does not get good results from so keen bats of epsom salts what are other methods of detoxification that you recommend dealing with live disease and hormonal positive breast cancer.
Well other methods of detoxification so I know we have it in our mind that I need to detoxify so therefore I need to do a detox or do a therapy that will aid in my detox.
Well there's truth in those statements we have to understand that you are detoxifying if you're not detoxifying you're going to be dead so you are detoxified so go back to that course that's why I created that course the seven phases of detoxification so you can understand what detoxification is there's a lot of half truths out there.
And this is why I'm so against Instagram influencers and TikTokers and all this stuff because they're just trying to get likes and shares and and down that's how they make money so they're just feeding with half truths but unfortunately throughout the decades there's a lot of practitioners that that okay we're going to put you on a detox because you need the detox and we're going to put you on a detox well.
That's partially true but understand you are already on a detox you are detoxing constantly so it's not we're going to put you on a let's just start using correct verbiage we're going to support detoxification so okay that's better but understand the reason why I made wrote the book and put the course together the seven phases of detoxification is you have to do things in order.
So like the question that was asked before this person's been constipated for nine months it is not been doing anything about it you're totally ignoring the benefits that you have by looking at the seven phases of detoxification and you're going to see the first step in detoxification is that you have to be eliminated you start with with phase six of detoxification if you are not having good solid ball movements and empty and clean out your gut on a daily basis.
You're poisoning yourself period. Don't forget it you have no business doing anything else you have no business trying to key late things out of your body you have no business I'm going to support my gallbladder you have no business I really need some liver support I need to do this detox if you're not having ball movements you start with phase six is going to phase five you go to the phase four the three two one and then you start doing phase zero which is pulling stuff out of the tissue.
So just go back to the seven phases of detoxification understand that pathway if you're having really good ball movements every single day then you could go back and start doing some of those other things make sure you're taking a binder supporting gallbladder function putting hot packs castell packs over your liver helping you know I already have you probably on things for phase one two and three in the liver.
And then you can start doing key lading things out of the body you are detoxifying so you know in the biggest reason why a person is not or has got slowed detoxification is they're not had not really dealing with gut issues so they're not really empty their balls on a daily basis.
If you're not doing that there's things to help you I mean you could go on Cape Aloe you could go on you know if you can't do coffee animals you just making sure that you're empty no the purpose of coffee
and if you want to know how to stimulate the parasympathetics without doing coffee animals go to the member site look at the whole section on parasympathetic sympathetic balance go to the blog post and look up parasympathetic and you'll see you could download some BDF forums on how to stimulate your parasympathetics and how to calm your symptoms.
There's a whole bunch of different neurological exercises one could do that go beyond coffee animals so that's the neurological side of detoxification but go back to the course the seven phases of detoxification and go through that again that's going to be your respect.
I was reading recently about Bartonella affecting micro circulation in the body and that's very true so Bartonella infections can cause like stretch mark looking things on the skin and all sorts of problems.
I wonder if that is what is causing the agonizing pain that I get my thighs when I walk even 10 steps or stand more than a minute very possible.
Lyme disease and co infections of life are notorious for those type of symptoms.
Like there be any frequencies of the right machine that could help address the issues with micro circulation to help provide some pain relief absolutely nothing is helped with the pain.
Well I would go right to the Bartonella program so there's program for all the Lyme co infections so you can run those the Lyme has Bartonella in it but you can run the Bartonella program.
So there's all the co infections programs on the right I would do those not the micro circulation there is a circulation program too but I would go to that root cause of running the frequencies.
I would go right to the root cause of the Lyme disease for the co infections.
Question from the from the chat I am taking 5000 milligrams of vitamin C divided daily vitamin E and others like SCAC.
Is this okay or too much antioxidants okay so you know you've been on my zoom calls for a very long time.
Taking 5000 milligrams vitamin C divided daily is I do not think that's the right thing to do for somebody who has cancer and the vitamin E depends on the dosage that you're taking.
Of the vitamin E if you're taking a fairly low dose of vitamin E that it's functioning as an antioxidant that you shouldn't be taking that either you have to increase the dose or stop taking it all together.
I do have a blog post on harnessed oxidated stress to kill cancer we've talked about it you know a lot on the zoom call about taking vitamin C orally so if you're taking 5000 milligrams at one time you're probably absorbing about 3000 milligrams.
And you could argue that that's a high enough dosage that it's not functioning as an antioxidant anymore it's functioning more in ox as an oxidant and at 3000 milligrams I would probably agree with that but if you're dividing the dose let's say you're taking 2500 in the morning and 2500 in the evening now your absorption of that 2500 is probably around 12.
1200 because you're really going to absorb about half of what you take orally you're probably absorbing about 1250 that's functioning as an antioxidant now I don't think you should do that so it's you you want to make sure you're taking a single dose in a high enough level of vitamin C that it's going to function as an oxidative agent to cancer and that is an antioxidant.
So if you're taking 5000 milligrams a day of vitamin C I would take a single dose and the vitamin E I can't remember the dose that you want to be at for an antioxidative stress level so go back to my blog post harnessing oxidative stress to kill cancer.
Next question how often should one run H. Pylori to have the right results you're talking about the frequency the program H. Pylori that's different for everybody I have people with chronic H. Pylori infection that are running in a couple times a day and they still at the right it's just not knocking it down so that you have to do you have to couple it with with the nutritional approach as well.
Next question I keep getting I inflammation both eyes and it comes and goes but getting more painful each time any suggestions oh wow.
Huh well I have you have you investigated the source is there something that you're that you're topically being exposed to that could be causing I inflammation but I don't know that's really not my specialty when I inflammation I but you want to look you have to think through this and think through possible causes is there some.
You know, dust that you're exposed to that you could have you know an allergic reaction to I don't remember your last blood work if you sit a Phil's were elevated suggesting possible topical type allergen.
I do you know anything else that you're putting on topically that could cause I inflammation.
And I like you personally both eyes you think it's something you're being exposed to and I've not heard of like food based things causing I inflammation but that's a tough one I would I'd go and do an eye doctor and see if they can investigate something going on I don't I don't know.
I don't I don't know I apologize.
Other questions.
Well we had a good zoom call today great a lot of questions came in really good questions.
Remind our new people to go on the member site.
These typically the zoom call will be uploaded that night onto our member a video site so you can see it otherwise the next day I'll try to get this one up tonight.
Otherwise everybody have a blessed rest of the week.
Thanks for being a part of this remember to be praying for your fellow comrades in this same fight that we're in a crazy world that we're living in today.
You know that we'll be praying for you and we cherish your prayers God bless everybody. Have a good night.